[Musique]
il regarde sa ville tranquille
il attend qu'il sait qu'il est fragile
difficile
et pourtant il ouvre ses grands yeux
airgas avant
[Musique]
e
le chômage à son nom
en bas
heureux
[Musique]
cet horizon de tous
qui l'entourent
l'asphyxient son univers
passez les jours ils ennuient
ce n'est que l'enfant
qui rêve de po
n'est ce pas
qui lui
eu lieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme
du bon
la vie
[Musique]
c'est pas toi
st
aussi
pendu
[Musique]
de café en café avec des amis
il passe son temps
m
il se souvient
eux jouent avec le feu
jour délinquants
et
[Musique]
qu'ils soient méchants
sympa
ceci dit
de francs
17 ans
villa
on sait le faire
ce voeu
et
la pole il se
ses parents sont fiers
comme dans un
comment
c'est ton nom
c'est le
même sens
[Musique]
c'est toi qui
nous
oui
[Musique]
nous
juste et
aussi
mon dieu
mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]